une contestation timide mais bien
présente
cette nuit à rangoon c'est au son des
casseroles et des claques sont que se
sont exprimés les habitants de la plus
grande ville du pays
une tentative de protestation au
lendemain de l'arrestation dos en
dessous çi on dit qu'un coup d'état
militaire a eu lieu mais je ne sais pas
exactement ce n'est pas une bonne chose
alors que l'école a été suspendu pendant
un an à cause du coc vide 19 le coup
d'état va faire perdre une année de plus
et c'est une évaluation a minima car
cela peut prendre deux ans et demi dans
tous les cas de figure les ducasses on
va accuser un net retard éducation mais
aussi santé le pays est déjà durement
frappée par le court aux navires us avec
plus de 140 mille cas et 3100 décès
recensés au niveau économique même bilan
350 millions de dollars dettes d'urgence
avait été envoyé le mois dernier par le
fonds monétaire international
mais cette nouvelle crise politique
risque de replonger le pays dans
l'isolément et à l'international les
réactions se multiplient
le ministre français des affaires
étrangères jean yves le drian a appelé
l'union européenne à imposer de
nouvelles mesures
les arrestations des dirigeants à aung
san suu kyi et du président de la
république ville min sont des actes
inqualifiables
si la situation se poursuit il faudra
envisager au niveau européen
des mesures supplémentaires pour marquer
notre soutien au processus démocratique
de l'autre côté de l'atlantique joe
biden a appelé à une réponse
internationale concertée pour
contraindre les militaires à renoncer au
pouvoir
mardi un conseil de sécurité de l'onu
s'est tenue en urgence mais ses membres
ne sont pas parvenus à s'accorder sur un
texte commun alors que au sandwich i
prix nobel de la paix 1991 et le
président win min serait assigné à
résidence dans la capitale
des membres du parti présidentiel la lnd
ligue nationale pour la démocratie ont
été autorisées à rentrer chez eux
ils sont venus
nous ont dit que nous étions libres de
partir à 1000 continuerons à faire ce
que le partout nous demanderons une
résistance silencieuse avec pour relais
les réseaux sociaux ou de gêne birmans
ont lancé un appel à la désobéissance
civile
l'armée de son côté dirigée par le
général et ming liang a mis en garde
contre toute incitation aux émeutes et à
premier la tenue de nouvelles élections
à la levée de l'état d'urgence
c'est-à-dire dans un an